for hundreds of years young and old have
headed up Penny van the highest peak in
South Wales but from today the park it
calls home the Brecken beacons is no
more a new kind of National Park not the
Brecken beacons national park though not
anymore no this place has a new name now
or rather an old one
adopting its Welsh name banai brakaniok
comes 66 years after it was granted
National Park status I think it's really
important to celebrate our culture Our
Heritage as you know as we mentioned the
name goes back to the roots of the kings
in Abraham and Welsh language and
culture is really really important to us
and to our visitors
the name change is just one part of a
new plan for the park to improve
biodiversity and tackle the impacts of
climate change promoting Welsh culture
and language may be a big part of this
Rebrand but for the Walkers heading up
penivan this afternoon the new name is
proving a bit of a mouthful can you
pronounce it nog
have a go
bad news
I'm gonna go with ban now Bryn kainiac
that's pretty close that's pretty that's
pretty close
perfect yeah but for the non-fluent in
Welsh fear not we're not saying happy
birthday has
today will but
be usually don't get in trouble if you
still say breakfast
damn Whitehead Sky News
South Wales